hello
hi my name is leslie knope and i work
for the parks and recreation department
can i ask you a few questions
would you say that you are enjoying
yourself and having fun
having a moderate amount of fun and
somewhat enjoying yourself or having no
fun
and no enjoyment i'm gonna put a lot of
fun
miss no there's a drunk stuck in the
slide
sir this this is a children's slide
you're not allowed to sleep in here
you know when i first tell people that i
work in the government they say oh the
government the government stinks the
lines are too long of the dmv
but now things have changed people need
our help
and it feels good to be needed could you
put your arms to your side
and that might help you slide down a
little easier you know do you want to
come this way
oh oh okay we're gonna need you to get
out go away get out of the slide
okay here we go okay please go away okay
wake up
here we go out of the slide you know
government isn't just a boys club
anymore
women are everywhere it's a great time
to be a woman in politics
hillary clinton sarah palin me nancy
pelosi
we did it you know i like to tell people
you know get on board and buckle up
because my ride's gonna be a big one
and if you get motion sickness you know
put your head between your knees cause
leslie knope stopping for no one tonight
is our next monthly community outreach
public forum and that is tonight
that is tonight right leslie will be
running it
and we need one more who wants in
tom ugh fine
hi hi i'm ann perkins uh i'm a nurse
and frankly i don't really care for
politics
uh but um i'm i'm here to talk about the
abandoned lot on sullivan street
excellent that sounds like a good idea
tell us about that no it's a problem
it almost killed my boyfriend oh yeah
there's a lot nearby my house
and a developer dug out a basement for
some condos and then they went bankrupt
so there's just this giant pit and it's
been there for almost a year
12 months yes go on yeah and my
boyfriend who
is a musician actually i support him but
anyway
he fell in and broke both his legs and
let me speak with you for a minute so
your boyfriend fell down into this pit
right yes
and um this guy is pretty serious you
guys living together
yes wow uh i'm sure this must be really
tough for you
you know just this guy sounds like he
didn't have a lot going on for him
to start with and now both legs broken
he's just weak
you have to take care of him you
probably feel like you need to move on
just become more adventurous in
relationships with your body just
are you are you actually hitting on me
right now
oh oh god no i'm not i'm not hitting on
you i'm actually married i'm just an
open person
and i like connecting with people i'm
you know very comfortable around women
attractive women i've spent a lot of
time with them and i just
i don't know i feel like we might be
taking up too much of the forum's time
maybe
we can just exchange numbers you know
maybe go away one weekend
and just kind of talk about this look
i'd love to do it the bottom line is
i've been trying to get this thing fixed
for months
and nobody's done anything and it's ugly
and it's dangerous and it's
government-owned and you need to do
something about it
okay i'll do something about it
really yes we i will help you is that a
promise
it's more than a promise it's a pinky
promise
honey can you straighten up your area a
little bit cause they're gonna be here
soon
thanks that perks lady is coming over
and we're going to go take a look at the
pit
i i think it's probably just a photo op
for her
i mean i don't think anybody in
government actually cares about honey
do you mind doing that somewhere else
i'm trying to watch tv
i'm talking about the pit you fell in
it's ms perkins house
doorbell yeah i heard it
doorbell i heard it i'm getting it
i'm here hey wow look at that
safety you remember tom from last night
yeah how are you
of course i do and this is our college
intern april she's going to be
documenting our fact-finding mission
april hey it's just fun for you
yeah it's so much fun uh i'm just gonna
grab my phone quickly
this must be our hero the man
heard round the world uh-huh how you
doing son
are you i'm leslie knope
and the entire government of pawnee
would like to
let you know that we will do everything
we can to help you
did you pass me my itch stick of course
hello hello oh hey how are you
hello there hi chris traeger this is ben
hello gents ron swanson ron
swanson okay
i'm deputy director leslie knope and
leslie
nope it is fantastic to be here
would you gentlemen like a tour oh there
is quite literally nothing i would
rather have in the world than a tour of
the parks and recreation department of
the great city of pawnee
led by ron swanson and leslie knope
okay ben i don't think that's a great
idea let's do it
right chris is the most positive state
budget auditing consultant i've ever met
i mean i made eye contact with him and
it was like
staring into the sun people
we are here from the state budget office
from indianapolis
what does that mean well simply we are
here to tinker with your budget
think of the government as a broken down
carousel
we're gonna slap on a new coat of paint
we're gonna fix that broken speaker
system
and we are going to get those happy kids
back up on the horses where they belong
okay yeah okay
okay yeah yeah that's not bad there it
is my uh partner ben is gonna stick
around for a little bit and
i will see y'all later adios
do you have a second
i really like your shirt i'd like to
talk about where you think there's waste
within your department where do i start
what exactly will you be cutting and how
much of it and can i watch you do it
while eating pork cracklins
leslie knope chris traeger i just want
to say that getting to know you
and watching you work has been
one of the greatest experiences of my
life that
and working with dr richard niger sure
and i just want you to know that i
thought there was no man on earth good
enough for ann perkins
and i still think that right but if
there is no one
actually good enough for her you are
pretty damn close
okay well this is normal no big deal
drive safe we will i packed you some
sandwiches
and some caffeine free iced tea so oh
and there's a mix cd that i made already
loaded in your car
there's a lot of sarah mclaughlin so
chris i apologize things are gonna get
emotional
i love you i love you too
to do it the swing is fixed
well there you go sir local government
at its very best
actually none of these people works in
local government
this is a group of private citizens and
one misguided federal employee meddling
where she does not belong
for once could you just no
in any case another problem solved by
the hard work of dedicated public
servants
okay great bye
yeah that's about right okay well
hang on gail made me promise to get a
quick picture just for old time's sake
good idea gary had a good idea
ah the lighting's all wrong i'm gonna
send you a glamour shot just photoshop
me in later i'm not gonna show up in
that picture
anyway because i'm a vampire hey babe
for this picture should i be bert
macklin
johnny karate or my new character
sergeant thunderfist
md where did you get that found in the
sandbox
whoa go macklin aquan's the hottest get
on with it
i can't hold this smile forever i look
ridiculous okay hang on
okay
you ready babe
yes
i'm ready
you